juntos la lista de manuel macrón ganó
por décimas esta primera vuelta han
perdido siete puntos respecto a hace
cinco años un sondeo del instituto ifop
les da entre 275 y 300 diez diputados en
segunda vuelta la mayoría absoluta está
en 289 escaños
la primera ministra macro ni sta hizo un
llamado a su electorado
solo una mayoría fuerte y clara nos
permitirá responder a las cuestiones
urgentes que pesan sobre la vida
cotidiana de los franceses y hacer
frente a los desafíos del futuro
histórico es el resultado para la nueva
unión popular ecológica y social
liderada por jean-luc mansión todo
apunta a que será la principal fuerza de
oposición
la realidad es que el partido
presidencial tras esta primera vuelta
está derrotado y bach
la ultraderechista agrupación nacional
de marine le pen quedó por detrás esto a
sus votantes a negarle una mayoría
absoluta a la lista de macrón pero sin
votar la lista de milán son
no elijan entre los que quieren
despojarle de sus derechos y los que
quieren despojarle de sus bienes francia
no es ni una bolsa ni una zona
anarquista
más de la mitad de los franceses no
fueron a votar en un récord histórico lo
analizó para france24 pascal duo
y que es muy importante volver a lo
cotidiano volver a la vida real de la
gente de los compatriotas cuya mayoría
enfrenta dificultades sociales
en esta es afección si macro no llega a
la mayoría deberá buscar pactos para
tirar adelante su programa